today on the matt walsh show the nfl and
nba pretend to take a stand for
social justice but it's all an act they
have always run
from every opportunity to help fight for
real justice we'll talk about that also
five headlines including nancy pelosi
becoming the latest democrat politician
to break the lockdown rules but it's
okay because you know she's important
and in our five headlines i'll cancel
all of the white adherents to the
critical race theory cult who are
running around begging forgiveness for
their inherent racism i got a couple
uh pretty hilarious but sad examples of
that to play for you
um that and plenty more to discuss on
the show today but first a word from
lifelock if you're on the internet every
day as i know you are because you're on
it right now
then you leave yourself wide open to the
bad guys who might want to get your
information
steal it this is especially a problem
now with in
with the increase in cyber learning you
know it's really important especially to
protect your kids
and that's why you need lifelock you've
got to make sure that their personal
information is safe
as there are risks involved especially
with using mobile devices
remember you know a couple tips here to
review the security settings and privacy
policies
for any social media sites they use and
uh caution against checking in with
their apps to announce their location
like your apps are always asking you to
do make sure they don't do that most of
all
make sure they're not sharing any
sensitive or personal information online
including anything that can help
a cyber criminal steal their identity uh
listen what it comes down to
is this every day we put our information
at risk on the internet
and you could miss certain identity
threats by just monitoring your credit
that's why there is lifelock nobody can
prevent all identity theft or pro
or monitor all transactions at all
businesses but
you can find out if your information is
on the dark web get your free dark web
scan at lifelock.com
walsh pick the plan that's right for you
so it's up to you you save up to 25
off your first year uh that's a free
scan at lifelock.com
walsh and 25 off again
lifelock.com walsh
okay so two months ago drew brees was a
superstar athlete who had managed to
pull the rare trick of being famous
successful
and universally beloved the latter being
by far the most difficult feat of the
three but then the new orleans saints
quarterback stated publicly and
correctly that
protesting during the anthem is
disrespectful and that it's better to
stand together and quote show
unity and this unleashed a torrent of
criticism which brees withstood
courageously for all of 24 hours before
folding like a beach chair
and apologizing profusely for his
defense of unity and patriotism
and these days brees can be seen running
around the practice field with
the name of an accused rapist and serial
abuser who was shot after assaulting
police officers
taped to his helmet his transformation
from a beloved and admired sports star
to a sad capitulating pathetic pawn
is complete now drew brees was once
considered a face
of the nfl and by displaying this utter
lack of moral fortitude and by rallying
behind an accused domestic abuser and
sex predator
he has proven that he still is a face of
the nfl
the nfl like the nba has many faces and
together they create a collage
that forms the appearance of a
gelatinous sea creature
something with very thin skin and no
muscle
and no spine um in recent months
and especially since the shooting of
jacob blake both sports leagues have
been engaged in all manner of publicity
stunts designed to make them look like
they care about racial justice and of
course you know
fans of the wnba would have seen similar
theatrics if those fans
well existed but the baltimore ravens
just as an example baltimore ravens
issued a statement shortly after the
blake shooting
a day or two later declaring despite a
total lack of evidence and context
that the police officers are murderous
races now it's interesting that the
ravens were
far quicker in responding to the
shooting of a guy in wisconsin
than they were in responding to their
own player beating his wife in a hotel
elevator
that was ray rice you may remember that
and you know historically the nfl has
done an abysmal job of enacting justice
within its own ranks often allowing
abusers to continue collecting game
checks
until public pressure forces them to
take action but you know suspending your
own star players or expelling them from
the league entirely
is a real and meaningful measure that
might cost them money and bring bad
publicity
it's much easier to paint end racism
onto the field which is what they're
they'll be doing in every stadium this
year and allow your players to wear the
names of alleged
police brutality victims on their
uniforms because these measures are
performative self-congratulatory and
achieve
absolutely nothing of value in other
words they're exactly what we've come to
expect
from the nfl we've also come to expect
them to steadfastly support abusive and
violent men like
jacob blake it's what they've been doing
after all
for decades now seattle seahawks coach
pete carroll um
did his part uh in the fight for truth
and justice by appearing on late night
with seth meyers
wearing a shirt that said equality well
that'll do it
later he delivered what we're told by
the media was a raw
and impassioned speech about racism you
know it's funny how these raw
and impassioned speeches about racism
always seem to be delivered exactly when
raw and impassioned speeches about
racism
are what everyone expects and demands of
you but whether or not it was
raw and impassioned there was certainly
nothing bold or brave or honest or
important
in carol's long lecture to his fellow
white people
bold honest brave important that would
have been a call for the public to
withhold judgment about police shootings
until the facts are known if you really
want if you really wanted to be brave
he would have come out fully in support
of the police and patriotism and peace
but pete carroll is not a brave man uh
there are a few of those
in the nfl these days now the nfl
may be a paper tiger when it comes to
social justice but
they look downright ferocious compared
to lebron and friends over the
in the nba um perhaps all that needs to
be said about the nba
is that the players boycotted their
games in response to the blake shooting
a stupid reason to boycott but at least
they're putting their own money on the
line
only to end the boycott and continue
playing the very next
day the nba has perfected the art of
faux
activism winning fawning praise from the
media
while doing precisely nothing the same
theme emerges
you know when the league and its members
had a chance to take a meaningful stand
for human rights one that would have
made a difference yet potentially cost
them dearly cost them billions of
dollars even
they decided to ignore the human rights
abuses in china in favor of continuing
their lucrative business relationship
with china's communist regime golden
state warriors coach steve kerr
rather famously curled into the fetal
position and feigned ignorance when
confronted about china's atrocities last
year
when he was asked about it he said that
he's still quote trying to learn about
the issue
doesn't want to jump the gun and talk
about it before he's learned
yet the team published a statement on
the blake shooting within days
condemning the police department and
passing their own summary verdict
it's strange that there was no time
taken to learn in that case
to learn for example what actually
happened
and other minor details now for his part
um
lebron james is is commenting publicly
now on
every high profile shooting but but only
the high profile ones
his concern for violence against black
men seems to extend only as far as the
news cycle coincidentally
lebron has uh repeatedly declared that
he is scared
as a black man in america and that black
people are literally hunted
every time they leave their comfort of
their own homes
this of course is nonsense lebron james
doesn't really believe that he's a liar
and it's dangerous nonsense the sort of
nonsense that burns
cities but lebron will continue spraying
gasoline into the inferno from the
comfort of his
nba bubble or his los angeles mansion
america has given lebron
wealth fame power and admiration
beyond imagination like so many of his
peers though he has a very funny way of
saying thank you
so in summary these men and
organizations are
hypocrites and moral cowards they give
us the spectacle of big
strong athletes performing feats of
strength and skill
sprinkled down with a healthy dose of
social justice banner waving
but on the inside at the core of their
characters they are frail
and pitiful these are most of all men
desperate for approval
if they're scared of anything it isn't
that racist white men are hunting them
it's that the checks might stop coming
and the applause might cease
and this cushy life afforded to them by
the country they despise
might disappear so they're never going
to use their platform to defend true
justice or speak real truth
instead they'll posture and earn their
millions and cry into their piles of
money
about the oppression that they have made
up in their heads
let's get to five headlines
[Music]
you know when i first got married uh and
my my wife
uh had to she had to briefly live in my
bachelor pad apartment before we moved
uh god bless her that could have been
easy but you know one thing she noticed
when she walked in is that the walls
were completely bare aside from the odds
stain or two
um but that's because i didn't have any
artwork on the walls and it wasn't till
i got married and i
you know so you start having your own
home and you realize you got to have
some artwork on the walls and that's
where paint your life comes in i wish
i'd known about paint your life
back then if you want to give a truly
meaningful gift you've got to go to
paintyourlife.com get a professional
hand-painted
portrait created from any photo at a
truly affordable price
you choose from a team of world-class
artists and work with them until every
detail is perfect
uh user-friendly platforms let you order
a custom-made hand-painted portrait in
less than five minutes
so this whole process on your end is
really quick really easy
much more than you think it will be um
but on their end they've got real
artists working on this the other thing
is it's hands-on for you throughout the
process so
you know you get opportunity for
feedback um
and they want to know you know they want
to know if you like it and if
and if they want to know what direction
you want the painting to go
um and you know it makes the perfect
birthday anniversary or wedding gift or
it's just something you can
get for yourself uh that's what we did
in my family
so at paintyourlife.com there's no risk
if you don't love the final painting
your money is refunded but you will love
it
i'm telling you and right now as a
limited time offer get 20
off your painting that's right 20 off
and free shipping to get this special
offer text the word matt to 64 000
that's matt
to 64 000 text matt to 64
000. paint your life celebrate the
moments that matter
most okay nancy pelosi is the latest
democrat politician to break the
shutdown rules
that she pushes and supports uh and once
again like the mayor of chicago
it's all so that she can get her hair
did as the kids say
i think uh here she is nancy going to a
hair salon
maskless indoors san francisco
to get a blowout whatever that is
honestly when i first heard that nancy
pelosi was caught indoors for a blowout
i thought it was some kind of bathroom
emergency
and at first i thought well okay i'll
give her that i mean you know look you
got to do what you got to do
but i know apparently it's uh it's some
sort of hair thing so
it's illegal right now in the city to
get your hair done inside especially
maskless
but nancy can do it because she's nancy
pelosi now
the pelosi camp has responded to the
controversy their excuse
their excuse is something else their
excuses that she didn't know
that what she was doing was wrong
seriously that's what they're
saying she didn't know she didn't know
about the rules that she has
ceaselessly promoted and insisted upon
and that's absurd obviously but on
another level in in a certain way i
almost believe it i almost believe
that nancy pelosi really didn't think
she had done anything wrong but not
because she didn't know the rules
but because she really didn't think they
applied to her now nancy pelosi's been
in congress for 376 years i think so
she's been in this bubble
uh not living a real human life for so
long
it may just be that she really assumed
that
the rules didn't apply to her i can
almost imagine the conversation with one
of her henchmen when they say uh you
know
speaker pelosi people are upset that you
went in to that hair salon
what upset what do you mean well because
it's illegal and you know you've
supported these laws and now you're
doing what and
people think it's hypocritical but wait
hang on a second but i'm nancy pelosi
did you explain that to them no did you
explain to them i'm nancy pelosi
do they know that it's it's it's me i
mean i said what do you expect me to
follow the same rules as the dirty
smelly regular people that's absurd
um and then she soothes herself by
eating five cartons of
ice cream from her 95 thousand dollar
refrigerator
uh but whatever whatever the excuse is
this this just
really what it confirms again is that
the people in government
um who've been fear-mongering about the
virus and using it to control us
don't believe what they're saying all
right let's go to number two the media
right now is having a difficult time uh
so prayers up for the media because
they're they're having it's
it's it's a hard time for them we've got
these riots going on
uh but the media can't decide if it
should
deny that the riots are happening or
blame the riots on donald trump that
that's what it really comes down to they
can't figure it out
so they're kind of doing both at the
moment the moment they're they're trying
to split the difference
and that's why you have this headline
from the new york times uh the headline
is as right-wing groups increasingly
move to confront protesters in u.s
cities
demonstrators are assessing how to keep
themselves safe
uh yes of course
yes that's what's happening here well
with a few with a few tweaks
this is a good headline so i think it
just needs to run through the editorial
process a little bit more
here's how i would adjust it this is
what i would say for the headline
as citizens increasingly decide that
they don't want their houses and
businesses burned down
arsonists are assessing how to continue
their campaign of terrorism
in a way that harms others but not
themselves so
you know very similar but just some
minor changes
anyway that's one strategy to say
yes there's violence but actually
somehow it's all right wingers which
raises the question
if right-wingers are causing all this
violence at left-wing protests
why don't you ever see violence at
right-wing protests i mean you never see
it you never see buildings getting
burned down to right-wing protests
do they save all of that for the
left-wing protests
it's a pretty pretty dastardly genius
plan if so but somehow i doubt it
but then you also have
the media at the same time claiming that
the riots aren't happening at all
which gives rise to one of my new
favorite genres of tweets where
journalists
in the nicer more comfortable parts of
riot racked towns take pictures and and
videos of little plots of grass
where nobody is being beaten unconscious
or killed at the moment
and they offer it as proof that the
riots are fiction so here's dan
zak journalist two first names so you
know that you gotta have be on your
guard with this guy
reporter for the washington post and um
i mean if you're like if the last name
zack i don't think you
name your kid dan dan zack
i don't know i i think if you if you've
got the a first name for a last name
then you've got to have a last name for
a first name i think that's the way that
it works
the two first name thing it's creepy
anyway dan zak
uh he he uploaded a little video of some
people sitting on the grass with the
sarcastic caption
washington dc is simply out of control
you see you get it because those six
people there on the grass
aren't murdering anybody right now
therefore there's no problem in dc
makes sense and then josh campbell cnn
correspondent shows us some grass in
portland
with the caption good morning from
wonderful portland where the city is not
under siege
and buildings are not burning to the
ground i also ate my breakfast burrito
outside today
and so far haven't been attacked by
shadowy gangs of antifa commandos
oh okay so josh had a burrito this
morning
and wasn't killed which means logically
that buildings are not burning down in
portland do you understand how that
works
it's airtight you know speaking of which
look i have this uh i
i have this here i found this online
this is a satellite image
of the middle east and as you can see
you know there's nobody in this picture
shooting anyone or blowing themselves up
that we can see
so yeah looks real dangerous all this
stuff about the middle east being
dangerous
you can see look you see syria right
there do you see anyone
being executed by islamic militants in
that picture do you
you know what else um you've probably
heard of the hindenburg disaster
supposedly supposedly allegedly a german
airship caught fire in 1937 killed like
36 people
uh that's what you heard that's the
story but i can debunk that right now so
here's the picture um but anyway just
sorry zoom in on not zoom in on the on
the tip of the
of the airship the part that isn't on
fire there you see see that
the ship didn't catch fire you see
because that
you can see right there that part of the
ship that's not on fire which means that
the other part isn't either super scary
hindenburg disaster you've got there
[Music]
debunked i just did it myself uh
it's it's it's easy to do all right
number three here's a lovely sentiment
from a former blm organizer and current
contributor to medium
she says this is a tweet she sent out
she says
i absolutely hate the smile that white
people who don't know you give you
walking down the street to let you know
they're a sanctuary
safe white so no problem here just a
woman
who hates white people for smiling
imagine being this angry i mean i'm
angry but she gives me a run for my
money i
even i don't get mad at people for
smiling most of the time
but this this is this is extreme like
top
shelf barrel proof racism you're dealing
with right here
where she she is she she hates people of
another race even when they're smiling
not just even winners she hates them for
smiling
but this is a blm organizer and someone
who feels perfectly comfortable
expressing this out loud publicly on the
internet
with her own name and face attached to
it which should tell you something
now by the way i checked out her bio on
her website
and this will shock you first of all she
describes herself as an award-winning
poet educator
author activist and journalist
and also she appears to use the pronoun
they
so both are shocking developments there
and on her twitter account her most
recent retweet
is from someone named feminista jones a
left-wing activist apparently verified
account on twitter
um explicitly calling for and condoning
violence against white people
here's what here's what the she says
feminista jones
begging white people to support blm and
related work has diluted the integrity
of true revolutionary
work i still don't get why folks were so
focused on
getting mainstream support when it only
means the inevitable destruction of the
movement
white white people no matter how liberal
or progressive will never endorse
revolutionary acts that may jeopardize
their children's lives
i wonder why and then she continues
violence is the only way of course no
votes no marching
no spots on cable news no high fashion
magazine cover stories no hashtags no
panels
none of that is going to bring about
liberation that black folks deserve
what if i told you that violence
requires that the violence required is
liberating what if i told you that
there's no way for a
dislocated displaced african to truly
live free
without the complete destruction of
whiteness's occupation of space in our
minds bodies souls communities etc
and it goes on for a while after that
this is an explicit direct
call for racial
violence and it's extremely common from
the blm crew
but somehow the violence is all trump's
fault it's all instigated by right-wing
militias or whatever
meanwhile you have blm organizers
over here saying they're announcing it
they're saying no no no guys
we're violent we look we're we're
violent look at us we
we totally support violence we are so
into violence everybody
they're literally shouting it into
megaphones
and the media has their ears plugged
pretending they don't hear it okay
number four a quick one here headline
from the new york post
headline is nearly half of new yorkers
think nyc
is headed in the wrong direction
nearly half which again you know
brings up another new york post headline
from 1912 nearly half of titanic
passengers think
ship is headed in the wrong direction
you know both cases of course
um the real headline is is the other
half
what what the hell is the other half
thinking five finally for our most
important story of the day i wanted to
uh
um i want to leave a little bit of time
for this because this is this needs to
be discussed and it's important
an athlete named david rush in idaho has
just
finally broken the record
and you know we've all been waiting for
this moment he's broken record for the
the fastest time to move a cream-filled
cookie from the forehead to the mouth
now the record for other types of
cookies still stands
and of course the record for the fastest
time to move a pancake from the forehead
to the mouth has stood now i think for
2000 years
or something like that um and
okay let's let's just play the footage
so we have the footage here we can play
it
here is again this is david rush
performing this athletic fee let's watch
this
hey there folks it's david rush on
vacation at the yellowstone national
park entering the guinness world
challenge this week
had to find some off-brand cream-filled
biscuits to attempt to break this
guinness world record
thanks to my son for the help three
two one go
eat it
come on hold on all right so we're using
this kind
of creamy sandwich cookies
of course that middle layer in there
three two one go
eat it
come on well there you go i mean if
we're not watching the nfl anymore at
least we have this
but with our luck you know this guy will
start kneeling too and ruin it
but then i was uh upi.com has the report
on this story i won't read the whole
thing
except at the very end of their report
they say that
they kind of bury the lead they say uh
there was one participant who had a
faster time now
david rush did it at 8.8 seconds there's
another person who actually broke the
record had a faster time
but his attempt was disqualified which
seems like a huge scandal
they don't tell us why he was
disqualified they just gloss over it
but now you know imagine you've trained
your whole life for this moment you've
given
everything to this goal your marriage
fell apart you're estranged from your
children you lost your job you're
homeless on the street
all because you're giving every second
of your life to the goal of eating a
cookie off of your own face
and then you do it and succeed and they
disqualify you
incredible tragedy triumph tragedy drama
joy sorrow
uh that is the world of competitive
competitive whatever the hell this is
we're gonna get to our daily
cancellation in just a second but first
you know as part of our daily wire
audience uh there are a number of ways
to take in the podcast you may listen
on apple podcast spotify or you know
another podcast app
you may also watch on uh on youtube or
facebook or dailywire.com there'll be a
million ways to do it
bottom line we're making our content
available to you anywhere you watch or
listen and now we're introducing a new
upgraded experience daily wire is now on
apple tv
and roku so members can enjoy all of
visual elements on this podcast on your
big screen
either live or on demand find the daily
wire on apple tv or
roku and download today you have to be
an insider member to watch live so
head on over to dailywire.com walsh and
use codewa
watch not walsh use code watch at
checkout to get 50
off your memberships uh this deal won't
last long so act fast if you wanna if
you want live shows on your big screen
plus the one of a kind highly coveted
leftist tears tumblers of course
then uh you've got to go to
dailywire.com
walsh to get 50 off with code watch
walsh and watch and download the daily
wire on your apple tv and roku today
let's get to our daily cancellation now
today for our daily cancellation we'll
be canceling
all white members of the critical race
theory cult
really all members of all races should
be canceled if they're in the cult but
today we're focusing on the white ones
uh two pieces of evidence to present
first rod drear uh has the screenshot
apparently from a northwestern
university law school
uh a town hall meeting they did online
and as dreyer describes it
the meeting started with a ritualistic
denunciation of racism from all the
participants
and so really it sounds like an a.a
meeting except with white guilt instead
of alcoholism here's a screenshot
so you've got emily who says my name is
emily i am a racist and a gatekeeper of
white supremacy
i will work to be better first of all a
gatekeeper of white supremacy sounds
almost like she's a
gargoyle or something that sits outside
the palace and asks you a riddle if you
want to enter
i am the white supremacy gatekeeper
answer these three riddles and you shall
pass that's what it sounds like to me
that's what i think every time maybe
it's just me
um anyway then sarah says uh thank you
all so much
my name is sarah and i'm a racist i will
try to be better
and james says i'm james and i am a
racist
now hang on a second why didn't he say
he'd be better is he not going to try to
be better
what are you saying james that's pretty
disturbing well actually never mind
according to critical race theory white
people can't not be racist so
trying to be better seems futile
another recent example of this kind of
thing a report from the daily wire
tells us that closing an 11 30 a.m
catholic mass
last sunday in new york city pastor
kenneth bowler
asked mass participants to join him in a
racial justice prayer that acknowledged
and denounced
so-called white privilege as the
church's streamed mass
panned to images of george floyd briana
taylor and ahmad arbory
the church of saint francis xavier a
roman catholic parish and the jesuit
traditi of course
damn jesuits of course it's jesuit every
every time i'm telling you jesuits uh
showcase the images of the alleged
victims of racial
injustice at the front of the church to
this left side of the altar
um okay so that there's the story but
let's actually play we have we have
video of the of the racial justice
prayer have your
vomit buckets ready as we check out this
prayer watch
i now invite you to stand and in joining
us in the prayer for
racial justice by responding yes to each
of the following statements
do you support racial justice equity and
compassion in real
and human relations yes do you affirm
that white privilege is unfair and
harmful to those who have it and to
those who do not
yes do you affirm that white privilege
and the culture of white supremacy must
be dismantled wherever it is present
yes do you support racial equity justice
and liberation for every person
yes do you affirm the inherent worth and
dignity of every person
yes therefore from this day forward
will you strive to understand more
deeply the injustice and suffering white
privilege and white supremacy cause
yes will you commit to help transform
our
church culture to one that is actively
engaged
in seeking racial justice and equity for
all for everyone
yes will you make a greater effort to
treat
all people with the same respect you
expect to receive
yes will you commit to developing the
courage to live
your beliefs and values of racial
justice and equality
yes will you strive to eliminate racial
prejudice from your thoughts and actions
so that you can better promote the
racial justice efforts of our church
yes will you renew and honor this pledge
daily knowing that our church and our
community
our nation and our world will be better
places
because of our efforts yes
let us pray all right first of all
that's not a prayer that's an
affirmation of belief
in fact it's it's uncomfortably similar
to the renewal of baptismal promises
that they also do during mass usually
when there's a baptism
if you're not catholic that's the part
at the end of the godfather when michael
corleone is answering yes to
do you renounce satan in all his and all
his works and the other questions while
his hitmen are executing all the rival
mob bosses
this is also a renewal of baptismal
promises of sorts except it's renewing
the promises of your baptism into the
cult of critical race theory
and what you just saw there rises to the
level of literally sacrilege
with the photo of a violent criminal who
forced his way into a woman's house and
robbed her at gunpoint right up there on
the altar but even without that
this is blm marxist propaganda being
spouted by a priest
from the altar and i you know i think
it's important for us to understand
something
not all of this stuff is empty virtue
signaling a good portion of it is
certainly that priest for example i mean
that's that's nothing but empty virtue
signaling
i doubt that man is capable of really
firmly believing anything at this point
many of these baby boomer priests in
america are just hollow vessels of
platitudes and cliches that's all
they've ever been
they've been pastoring churches for
decades never in their lives have they
uttered a single meaningful word from
the pulpit
ever not even once the church is plagued
by these types so for him
yes i'm sure it is empty just like
everything else he says and does
but what about the people in in the chat
you know they're confessing their racism
perhaps it's just a gesture a virtue
signal it could be a cave to peer
pressure
or maybe not i mean this idea that all
white people are racist
and that we all must confess our racism
and actively work to dismantle it
even though again we can't because it's
inherent supposedly but
this is an idea that many people have
really bought into
now if you're an intellectually
susceptible person of a non-white race
it makes sense why you'd buy into it it
provides as we discussed yesterday
a convenient villain for your story
making a villain a scapegoat out of some
other
group some out group some other some
them well
that's a coping strategy as old as
civilization itself nothing new about
that
nothing confusing about it either but uh
no matter how intellectually
susceptible a white person is why would
they buy into this i mean
why would people in the group being cast
as villains actually accept and embrace
that role
what's going on with that well because
the priests and priestesses
critic of critical race theory know
something that every other cult and
religion
knows which is that humans deep in their
souls
struggle fundamentally with two things
resentment and guilt
the resentment and guilt are oftentimes
a bit formless and shapeless you aren't
sure why they're there or
where to direct them and so humans go
looking for outlets for answers for
reasons
why do i feel this way where do these
feelings come from
these are questions that people
especially these days spend a lot of
time asking themselves we are very
focused on our own feelings in this
culture
and depending on where you look you get
different answers psychologists will say
well those feelings are disorders
here take this pill self-help gurus will
say those feelings are illusions here
are some affirmation mantras you can
repeat in the mirror every morning to
make them go away
cults will say that they come from
wherever the aliens living in volcanoes
i think that's scientology
i may be getting the theology a little
bit wrong uh religions have answers too
christianity says this is our fallen
nature it could be conquered through
christ repent and believe
and critical race theory the newest
religion in america comes along and says
well
if you're non-white you have resentment
because you're a victim of systemic
oppression
if you're white you have guilt because
you are racist
and at some level you know it and here
is how to assuage
your guilt all you have to do is confess
your racism pledge to be anti-racist
take a knee raise your fist do this do
that here's the choreography here are
the prayers the mantras here are the
beliefs and opinions you must adopt
this will make you feel better this will
rid you of the guilt
this will explain everything going on
inside you
see i think i think all people are
looking for something that will explain
themselves to themselves that's what
philosophy is
what's what much of science is about
psychology politics all of it at some
level is an attempt by human beings to
figure out who they are what they are
and
why they are the way they are critical
race theory steps in to offer its own
rather
horrid explanations and it's not a
coincidence that it takes hold in a
culture
where the other avenues of explanation
the better avenues like religion
are waning it's also not a coincidence
that religion especially christianity in
the west
started waning when it stopped talking
about and acknowledging the darker
aspects of human nature
pastors like the one you just saw there
started saying well i don't want to talk
about guilt because
people will be uncomfortable and they'll
leave what they didn't realize is that
that's exactly what people want to hear
about they struggle with these parts of
themselves they come to religion for
answers
if you refuse to give those answers
they'll go elsewhere for them
enter critical race theory the new cult
the new religion
and one that is infecting the minds of
many americans especially younger
americans and destroying our country
in the process but today
i have put a stop to that uh with my
cancellation
because that's all it takes i wave my
magical cancel wand
and now sanity has returned you're
welcome
we will leave it there now that we've
solved society you know
i feel like that's that's enough work
for one day so we'll leave it there for
today have a great day everybody
godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio was mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
a republican ex-senator says joe biden
is more conservative than president
trump
california democrats pushed to legalize
pederasty and the mayor of dc wants to
demolish the washington monument
check it out on the michael knowles show
[Music]
you